or and new this morning school shootings
cyber bullying the impacts of the
pandemic they are all issues that affect
youth mental health but there is
something that you can do to protect
your child our Candace Charles joins us
here in studio this morning some very
important information and some tips
Candace
Mental Health Care stats are sobering
John and Heather take a look at your
screen here according to Mental Health
America Nevada it's the last in the
country when it comes to a higher
prevalence of mental illness in children
combined with lower rates to access of
care now in 2019 we ranked seventh in
suicide deaths with 12 percent of those
deaths were children and teens now
here's the Silver Lining Nevada now
ranks 12th in the nation now this can be
attributed to funding for programs like
the Nevada resiliency project the state
hiring its first use Suicide Prevention
coordinator and the American Rescue plan
dollars going toward needed resources
like free support groups through naming
and more counselors in our schools but
that's only slightly moving the needle
the mental health experts say we have to
continue to have the conversation to
destigmatize mental health so
legislators and districts continue to
pour funding into this Mental Health
crisis
our kids are really suffering our kids
are suffering the the numbers that
statistically show just that so we again
we had to meet our meet our students
where they are it's really important
that when they're at school they have a
safe and supportive School climate that
can help them address those things
and there are a number of ways you can
help on the state level reach out to
your legislators right now there are
two-month Health bills that can help
address mental health needs including
one of by Youth and for youth that would
require increase learning and support
for mental health education and
resources in K-12 most importantly folks
talk to your child the National Alliance
on Mental Illness suggests here we go
take a look at your screen here explain
mental health like a medical problem
like asthma or a cold that there's
things that you can do like take
medicine for prevention or relief talk
to them about what they're experiencing
and listen with curiosity and empathy
discuss self-care and prevention and
don't be afraid to ask about suicide now
if you need help call that number on
your screen there at 988 The Suicide
Prevention Lifeline we have additional
resources on our website 8newsnow.com
for now live in the studio I'm Candace
Charles a news now all right Candice
thank you very much very important to uh
to be focused on Mental Health to be
sure 6 30